salut les copains c'est moins pire est
claire je suis de retour avec mon
meilleur ami bull
vous vous rappelez famille que j'avais
adopté qu'elle est belle la baballe le
bibi j'ai réussi à en faire une famille
exemplaire bakoko cancre au croquet
croquer avec ses dents le sucre je suis
un chien je pars mieux que lui
et depuis pas longtemps pour fais moi on
trouve de boules a changé et les garçons
vous allez voir que dans deux secondes
bull va la regarder avec une tête vidéo
et la bouche grande ouverte
j'excuse allez-y mais c'est mieux parce
que charrie fia mais lui parler et parec
l'amour ça rend avec apparemment impute
au mur ben c'est pareil mais ça veut que
de la bouche comme si ça suffisait pas
il ya un nouveau à l'école
[Musique]
bon c'est nul qu'entraîneur on puisse
theron doublons éviter de quoi pas de
boules et une nouvelle patronne j'ai
l'impression qu'à pas très gentils vous
avez donc deux mois pour me pendre de la
bonne bande dessinée bien triste si
jamais j'y arrivais pas vous serez virés
j'aimerais depuis il est complètement
partie en cacahuète prévient vue fait
des bêtises
qu'est ce qui lui prend bien phu en
train d'uriner sur mes chaussures
j'avais pas vu je suis adapté et même sa
maman s'est mis à faire n'importe quoi
oui tu vas bien
et puis car faire toute leur éducation
[Musique]
la honte tu les connais tu es de rigolos
n'ont jamais vu
[Musique]
salut les copains c'est moi bill est
claire je suis de retour avec mon
meilleur ami bull voit bien les familles
que j'avais adopté qu'elle est belle la
baballe bibi j'ai réussi à en faire une
famille exemplaire lui d'autres ont su
sucre le peuple il a quand même quelques
problèmes d'élocution et la kro kro kro
croquer quand koke avec ses dents le
sucre je suis un chien je parle mieux
que lui mais depuis quelques temps ça
tourne plus vraiment être heureux
nous les artistes nous nourrissons de
notre malheur pour est d'origine a écrit
les misérables au les gens riches
j'essaie de comprendre la hausse est
parti en cacahuète et c'est pas facile
il fait pipi sur leur dis à papa qu'est
ce qui lui prend il vient faut plus de
bêtises alémanique
vous avez beau jour tu vois ça va nous
en train d'uriner sur mes chaussures
t'es con ça s'est bien passé j'ai eu 18
ans histoire faut arrêter d'être un
petit garçon modèle dès le matin et ça
continue encore et encore non mais tu
vas arrêter petit insolent qu'est ce que
c'est que ces manières bull et moi 2 et
là encore c'est que le début
[Musique]